et
[Musique]
bienvenue au tampon chez bio et passion
donc je suis getty turbo j'ai 37 ans je
suis gérant de la société bio et passion
qui est située sur le tampon depuis
l'âge de 21 ans je me suis intéressé au
monde de l'agriculture biologique et à
la réunion pour cela j'ai été d'abord
agricultrice avec une société de
production et distribution de fruits et
légumes bio et tout de suite après j'ai
vu l'intérêt et l'importance de monter
une unité de production pour cela j'ai
été accompagné de l'adie et de la bce
sur un montant de 16 mille euros cela
m'a permis d'avoir un investissement
pour pouvoir obtenir une entreprise aux
normes des règles sanitaires
alors actuellement donc j'ai une unité
de transformation de fruits et légumes
bio locaux donc cette unité de 300 m²
est destiné à la production des produits
très originaux surtout sur la gamme des
petits pots bébé donc on essaye de
promouvoir le bio à travers des saveurs
qu'on a oubliés comme les légumes lontan
le camp bar la patate douce la songe on
travaille également sur des produits
comme du vinaigre dû confier au ciel des
condiments des surgelés bio un ensemble
de produits destinés à tous types de
consommateurs on peut retrouver mes
produits donc sur la grande distribution
notamment dans les magasins bio et la
nouveauté donc dans les pharmacies où on
peut retrouver les petits pots bébé
l'entreprise bio et passion s'inscrit
dans une démarche écologique parce qu'on
soutient les agriculteurs en leur
prenant les fruits et légumes qui sont
non vendables qui sont abîmés on les
transforme on récupère les bocaux et on
leur donne une seconde vie
tous les produits qui entrent dans
l'unité de production sont 100 % bio
100% la réunion les agriculteurs vont
pouvoir nous ramener en très gros
volumes les produits qui leur semble a
légèrement abîmée d'où notre rôle de les
soutenir de les apporter un appui sur la
partie transformation et pour que le
produit est une seconde vie et surtout
en favorisant le produit pays le produit
la réunion à le produit longtemps dans
l'unité on essaye d'utiliser tous et de
tout récupérer notamment avec la gamme
vinaigre on va utiliser les produits péi
toujours comme le fruit de la passion la
banane le citron pour donner encore une
image du seul de ces légumes dans une
image de luxe finalement et innover avec
des produits non existant sur le marché
dans les produits pays rien ne se perd
tout se transforme pour les grands et
les petits